The knapsack problem shows the beauty of
a technique called dynamic programming.
With dynamic programming, you can make a
really complicated problem like this one
run much faster by breaking
it into subproblems.
Here, the subproblem was finding
the answer for a smaller weight.
You begin by solving for something
like a base case, a subproblem so
small that the answer is very simple or
trivial to compute.
We started with one object.
With only one thing to consider,
finding the maximum possible value for
any weight was simple.
Another common feature of a dynamic
programming solution is a lookup table
that stores solutions to subproblems.
We stored the maximum values for
different weight limits
in our lookup table.
Dynamic programming solutions take
advantage of these two things, solving
the problem for a trivial case and
storing the solution in a lookup table,
by using them to slowly add
complexity to a problem.
Another feature of a dynamic
programming solution is an equation
used at each step as you add complexity.
For us,
the equation looks something like this.
The equation often combines some values
previously computed in the lookup table,
sometimes with each other and
sometimes with a new value you introduce
like the value of whatever
object you're looking at.
We used the values already stored in
the table as we added new objects,
a technique often called memoization.
So we ultimately didn't need
to recompute them every time.
This is the hidden power
of dynamic programming.
You compute and
save solutions to smaller problems.
Then you don't need to calculate them
again for more complex problems.
It might seem like a simple idea, but
it can have a really powerful effect
on efficiency if it's done well.
One of the most useful skills to have
when going into a technical interview
is the ability to spot a problem that
has a dynamic programming solution.
It didn't come naturally to me at first,
but
after practicing by trying to solve a
bunch of dynamic programming problems on
my own, I started to get the hang of it.
One thing you need to look out for
is a complicated problem
that seems to require trying every
combination to find the solution.
You need to ask yourself, can I
break this problem into subproblems?
If the answer is yes,
then you've got a problem with
a dynamic programming solution.